one of the things we have to remember is
that just because um the business can
function with a distributed workforce
with an online workforce um
we know that there's a sacrifice you
know it's harder to build trust you know
if you if you've joined the company
during covid you've never physically met
any of your your colleagues or
co-workers you know and you know
it's much harder to build trust when we
don't meet each other we take for
granted that when we go to the office
that you know the little brief
interactions we have at work when you
walk past somebody in the hall and say
hello or that talk going into the
meeting and the talk coming out of the
meeting and bumping into somebody going
oh i meant to tell you something or do
you want a grab of coffee no one of
these things by themselves does anything
but over the course of time they
contribute to the building of trust to
the building of human relationships in
an online context we don't have any of
the in between
all we have is the meeting we log on we
log off that's it
and so what a lot of companies
haven't recognized is that building
trust online is possible but it actually
requires more work
what used to happen just relatively
organically now has to be now has to
happen prescriptively
so for example um i'm a huge fan of the
monday morning huddle we do one on our
team where on monday morning the whole
team comes together um and it's there's
no discussion of work or deadlines or
workloads or anything
it's a human call where we simply say
what's on your heart and mind and then
we answer some funny or poignant
question that's posed to us by the
person who's leading the huddle that
month
um
and and we simply talk about ourselves
and you learn a lot about somebody you
know somebody say oh i had a great
weekend with my kids and we went you
know we went hiking i didn't even know
that they had kids you know or somebody
will say to be honest it was a really
hard weekend um my father has cancer and
he's in the hospital and he took a turn
for the worst
and uh and we start to see each other as
human and we start to empathize and we
start to create relationship
and we start to get to know each other
but it's done prescriptively we make it
happen
um i'm also a huge fan of of turning on
a zoom for example and just working like
we're not actually working with each
other we're just in each other's screens
as we're getting our own work done it's
nice to have somebody there i'm also
believing about a huge fan of the
telephone
um you know zooms are tiring especially
when you have them all day
um you know it's fake
uh you know very often you know i'm
looking at a dot at the top of my screen
so that you'll think i'm making eye
contact with you but really i'm just
staring at the dot at the top of my
screen or if i'm staring at you
sometimes the placement of the camera
the screens what you see is this but i'm
looking right at your eyes
you know um and so i think a telephone
believe it or not is actually a much
better way to connect with somebody
especially when someone's distracted
when you can see that someone's doing
email you know while you're talking
there's no actual polite way to say can
you stop doing that and listen to me
please you know and we just sort of
do it
on the telephone if you hear someone's
distracted you go hello you there they
go sorry sorry sorry you know you can
actually catch people
and i find that those interactions you
know i'm a pacer i like to pace when i'm
on the phone when i'm thinking i can't
pace on zoom which means my thinking is
junk right when i'm on a phone call i
can walk around
i can walk around wherever i go and i
can talk to somebody and i can be much
more engaged i think we especially for
salespeople
use the phone
pick up the phone how are you wanted to
check in with you
you know have a conversation without
zoom
i actually think it's actually much
better for building relationship believe
it or not having zooms occasionally is
great too but i think we've we've under
we've forgotten we've forgotten how good
the phone is